Hello my name is Kane admins and today I was twenty nine. And I'm here
met more MacArthur right Lisa
Jackson and what happened last library for the obvious story project at
program Public Library three top story is an oral history project focusing on
East New York. Why don't you tell me a little bit more about where you
found
it
from you know when in
fact what do you want
to
do you know what I remember when you first move
you know going to school and.
You know that basically my big issue.
But I remember coming
here. When I came here.
Actually late sixty nine. But I really didn't come to live until
nine seventy.
So. I
remember. At that time I really didn't
have that many people here primarily you see.
Most importantly you know saying the same information why and why
only Shree between take him in so should I say and
then and then
by remains to
be one bed flat.
Surely that they are
your Baghdad a lot of
the street there's still a dense and
remodelling but much of what we have in our neighborhood. In that area.
There are eight. Deliberate you
know people who have been here for many many
years have gone
past but I remember
that when I first came here. My husband and
I it was such a flourishing of the new
lives. Vibrant place at that time they had
many stories. There was a restaurant that I don't know anybody.
You have a lot of Chinese takeout food on the corner. Bradford.
There is
that actual sit down restaurant chain restaurant we could
go and
sit there.
And when I see people sometimes about that.
Because we had built a beautiful of the year to come to before
leaving
me it was.
What they call a great night we could leave from
our senses walk to the Corning go to develop.
You know based on this
year we had schools bread
and bread bread.
Very furniture so again
between
while on the way down to brass
you know they pretty much on the block and that was the big furniture store
they sold everything right. It was
just much more flourish.
Here you can we don't have any more we
have little lounges where you could go and sit down have a drink.
Without you there. You know and it was night and
people
were much more friendly back then
and we often talk about it because
most everybody when you came out were talking to
you most people don't even knowing
it when you leave dream of a
neighborhood that some of the
things that I
remember. We didn't have twenty maps we had
one on.
The couple of the lounges we go to to go and
sit
down and maybe have a drink or have a case
might be.
What
we have presently on the corner now which we
need. We need more substantial
same neighborhood but unfortunately when you're on
private property. You
know they rent to whoever they
want.
We
had we
had benches in front
of what has
been.
Each one of the houses in front of the
house they were.
If you were working in the street you wanted to sit down you could sit
down and say. Yeah.
So like I said I don't want to pretty much just want to
juniors doing
it and then like I.
You know people are
friendlier at that time.
It was just hospital
and we have the homeless now you know
the
answer is the face
before I was in
the corner.
Right there in the car.
We had. Yet we
had people you know I think
it's not exactly.
And then they might arrive. Yet and.
I doubt. So many
things we
had
a good way to go. We
had nine news today and
you
know people could get that
paper for before they went to the
way more
friendly and we didn't have or what we have new right now.
I'm not saying
that some of it is not beneficial to the neighborhood
need twenty.
Grocery store or the new name they're using coal
Valley and valley.
See the way that the you know if you go
to there being from New York.
If you score.
If you lately is when you win any you
actually contract with flying.
You know the whole
thing people.
People just kept
it. A lot
better and unfortunately when some
people unable to cope with things
change and right. We see the furniture store all of that
with you know different just so in a laundromat and all
that that is how they want houses
here so people who live here in
the morning
have one round the corner so that they you know they're not
alone in a
restaurant while now there were two
levels saying maybe you. Two hundred to one on
the corner of their member when they had a two or three a one on
each lane or
all they
have and it was just so
different and like I said people were much more friendly and even
when did you moving
and
moving even.
People is so much more friendly than a
neighborhood really was a neighborhood where you hear about that village.
Right. That's what I'm even though it's about
like when I went to were thinking
how
did this all right
for him
her And you know there was no hassle or anything like that you know
the new go have a case might
be and se but for one
another
place and I think I'm a desolate that you know.
This is not the area. You know it's really not the
end I guess it's a situation like people said well you know
things change and I'm not going to change the place
changes in a
hive way but if that changes in
a positive way and it's just holding together.
To do
why then what is the purpose of your change and
neighborhood should change.
They then
need. If I'm horribly and I want to
go to Home Depot. I'll be able to go around corners and go.
You know there's one down around big man you know but whatever
I'm saying we're still.
You know we have a wider now because we're
related to the.
You know the you know that kind of business go see you know you go to the Klan.
And yet. All of that as for it we actually go out
of breath and
this
is yet
to.
Not just you. Yeah
but after the blackout. They had so
much looting. They never were able
to come back negative fact they needed a small store and
that and that didn't work and eventually they just moved
out and
we add anything in
here
DAV they already sold the movie theater with out of
this
is
really the most training
when how much money down flat.
They probably didn't do the Biltmore the
year and of course you know yes pay if you go and see
that side and there is none if they get it because they will lie
down with you know everybody wants to see that big fight.
You know. A lot of people couldn't get out of the driveway
close to call eyes or a
line and be a net that such a big
fat people came from all over.
So we had which we call a traffic jam here and
what happened
was after the role of the people got so excited.
When they were coming out they brought the lady the female
the bill.
The they broke the two doors. You know like
the glass door as they come out from the theater and she was
so upset and she said you know what I think this class still one at a
time and she said it again
and that became the now right. When I started going
down. You would.
Sure but what happened in the state is stayed
until she gave it up and then started
going down the deal is just a big dog because nothing was
happening and a toilet down and then just by
inches
there waiting for a developer or somebody to come in
to do something with it a long time for several
years and then the
property history that when you had a
fire that was all taken down. So here now we
are stuck with it and the
tree and the lot on the other side with the furniture store.
What is presently both it and them when they're
loading acid in bread. One of the black
out and then looting it down
you know she said many
neighborhoods or little we had a
school supply store around the corner where in the fantasy we're going to
be fit and. They took out
that. They say.
It's America and America. Right because if
they travel. They were solely taking steps.
They trampled the person to that right
away. So people were it
was OK that they were walking down the street with a washing
machine act and people the want to
refrigerator. You know every word you
know we were in the wrong
and then you talking about people more concerned
with what. After their property they
were
friendly that really was tough.
That was the beginning of the now. For
our neighborhood and you might say most New York because then they just took
it all away to the
right. They made the bird out
of. All of
that there is a man down around
the corner
at Bravo or whichever one there one knew.
That story changed names about four or
five times but that gentleman
that Benjamin Moore paint
still
and he you know people used to go for
the few little things that.
He was about the only thing
left and he tried to do it.
You know.
People listen to it.
And I was amazed that he was able to say because
there was
just so
go away.
Yeah he said.
From
basically.
OK the church out
for community. Use to be
a street.
You also have the rest right.
Because it has a staff that
beautiful really play a you could also go there
have been three they have and they are yes
over the years like. You say probably after that.
They all are a big
cage and little
club. Until they went and they used to have
this is called the The chicken place
of chicken the last delight.
Belles was live and that of course to
change
factor. You also had another
movie
theater
but it was actually the movie The pit bull.
Let's say going back
to the midst of a yeah
you really is that X. rated that
she was it was always actually.
I added which is that what
shirts still have that sisters on Saturday.
Releasing those that live.
Yes So it was that was the church but it used to
be part of school.
So those are the little things I remember we had
those hospitals that we had them to live
across from. The story to
say was that this became active but
it was first and OK you had a little
boy with a nappy
and. We used to
have a lot of
spillage even in
Norway and then.
And then in Africa with the name of the system within
the but they had stories to tell to
day.
I can't get used to the fact that it is related.
You know now that the movie has gotten about we talking about horses.
We have what we have was.
And it was a developing
story yet. The big thing they had to
tell them as they do is that
they turned it
off and I think people would be down the years and
they would buy that at
last you
know and people used to talk about it I remember the pain
and
their salaries and not like you know later on.
Things happened has always been
a popular place that people refer
to their remember. That
means
that you have. I actually went to see it
as full of a lot of.
What I was told about. Three
was when they were still usable do nothing but rolled over
in the bowl of
water and so it
is people without
the will to live so it was a
scale. Basically still
very very powerful. Yes when
they had my candy or that.
Street
also then so they're going to
say the
name of stable
where all the road from without
the I'll talk about gold. We need
the
reality. But it isn't been laden
with all that you see that
know that God
is God reached
at Langley you will find me.
So what happens is alright city when the first thing.
When you with all
the cynicism
mocking a lot of people saying why are
you so much for a in.
My seat and checking out. Now
when in the quest to lose weight for so many years. You
know what they did
this or that all over the road.
So when they are sorry to be in a lot of people don't talk
about that.
When you use the gold and then you will get a funny.
This is after the bill is already on top.
So you get the slow flight and they have a real
bad problem and brand
building infestation roaches in
my boat out of saying I want to
live there but you know it's in the area
that he tells me about the time that
you ride to the
you know the and or the factory
where at the time
that the truck would come
through and they had a lot coming from the window.
Most of these are just to level.
They
would take like let's say we doing
silly like that maybe you need to do is leave.
The main
the the front of the jacket or
whatever coming from the
wind and the truck comes through and they
would say the did whatever they
had
completed whatever they would send it down the road
and
the person with the truck with take
their receipt that and then they would send him up another back to the
wind and they were duly peace
for that long before
I came here. You know.
I had this issue
that said you know
we're talking imagine growth coming out of the window like
Oh right yeah all of that but also the.
The movie house that was very popular they said
and said I think you're
a big movie and a lot of the talk.
They don't
believe
Ralph but it is
very
close
call they hear people talk
about that I could
never actually
land
or what have you had this was back
in the day James Brown to pig
out to be a good
and
human man great
that he
did that when I used to be affiliated.
And you know when I come you know.
So when
he came to pick
the
right thing
in
the edit. So I really have any
ammo with my first
choices here refer to
Brooklyn going to
stick
to the many words
that you know
uses that country
and for
that man
that he
would tell you have. Goes
all the talk
about that
no that we know
you have to
get the ball with me. So
this
was to the right where we have
right now.
Place
the year across the street by
street
name because the wallet is even we used to
bury the Black Berry a grand I
mean
sure you know that
the
web.
No longer around.
But
Ed Brown
was the
C.E.O. But what happened
was when
making money for
a different neighborhood
where
they were
giving then more money than they were
giving you
right
it was never a separate issue.
It became a separation when. And they
said
that they wanted to be given more
than
that around
speaking if you look at
it with the New York.
Going to get to
leave.
I
think the stand was now
here they don't know
really New York.
Certain who for whatever reason.
There's more negativity.
Which
people really don't want to live in the papers and
the beautiful par.
Bad Reputation.
But
first here.
What about.
They grow and.
Never come back or whatever the case. Allen
hole
that some form of fashion could be
some kind of fish. To it so that
they
know more of their
preferences once represented
and hopefully in the future will continue to
represent bring us back to where we
were and maybe it would teach
them to
respect and care for the community a lot
better than I know there's not much for them to do
the you know we need more that you know so I want to go
and talk about
the recreation of the men here we need.
It's coming but it's not here.
I just feel
like you need seven street shows and
big
sell. Or what have you
maybe to maybe use utilize a lot of Barry.
And maybe have sessions and say hey you know come to the
library and learn about Lee live.
You know but they have to be there if you start. You need
to go. They're not going to come in till they see that you're
really good about it and it's not like a one time thing
because these kids need to know
about you
know they need to be
taught. Community.
Here they
make
you
think
may.